we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day many people do call at
very unusual times of day let's listen
to the voicemail that came in yesterday
especially played chess what is your
favorite opening and what is your
favorite defense to any opening yeah or
a certain type of open okay for your
time yeah so last week on audience
questions I was asked if deep hackman on
chess calm is really me and if I'm that
bad at chess and the answer to both
questions was yes I play on chess calm
and my rating is not very very good and
since then you'll be interested in this
pad dozens of people have challenged me
to chess games on chess calm and most of
the people are way better than I am so
I'm losing most of those matches even
though I've accepted every single one
and it's it's gonna pull my rating down
but that's okay it's a learning
experience
they probably wear that as a badge of
honor I destroyed David Pakman at chess
yes he'll destroyed him yes I've been
getting destroyed I mean it is frankly
embarrassing um but listen I'm not even
good enough to have a favorite opening I
mean when I'm white I open with the
King's pawn right that I do at King's
pawn happening if I am playing black and
white opens with King's pawn I will also
put my pawn I will I will move up my
King's pawn as well and then beyond that
I'll usually play you know kingside
night or queenside night that that's
usually my move or I'll back up my pawn
with the Queen's pawn depending on what
what black or white is done depending on
which side I'm playing but I don't even
I'm not even at the point where I just
literally try to make an analysis on any
individual move that's been made I don't
even have favorite openings at this
point yeah I know some people want us to
like play chess live during the show
yeah
and have a segment about that right but
I would get crushed because I know how
the pieces move and I know like the
basic rules of the game yeah but that's
about it so it wouldn't even be that
entertaining I still think that like for
charity maybe it would be interesting or
as a fundraiser where we do like each of
us makes a move when X number of patreon
contributors yeah contribute or
something like that
and that would be kind of an interesting
thing and we could even set it up on
Ches comm so people could follow the
game like we could link to the game and
make it a publicly available game people
could watch it I think that there's
something there I'd like that could the
audience contribute like could we both
work with different members of the
audience no no no y-you could be team
black that would be crazy
okay yeah much we're definitely not
doing that now I like some of the ideas
but then this is where I'm sort of
drawing the line we would have to just
play against each other we wouldn't take
advice from the audience but there's
something in there you know I actually
still I'm not even good enough yet there
will be some times where there will be
I'll be playing against someone and they
won't be very highly rated and they'll
make a really unusual early move and I
will not be able to tell whether they're
just terrible players or they're trying
to use like an early checkmate trap that
I still am not even able to identify and
protect myself from so sometimes when
that happens I'll actually have an easy
game and easily defeat someone other
times someone will make like a very
early Queen move out to the flanks and I
will end up getting like checkmate trap
too because I don't know how to block
that's fascinating do you think this
will be your new favorite pastime
absolutely for the next six weeks and
then beyond to painting or something
like that now I like chess I plan to
continue playing we have a great bonus
show for you today but I'm out of time
just trust me folks it's a good one
today we'll talk to you then